es ist zu spät wenn es eine intelligente
zivilisation in unserer nachbarschaft
gibt dann hat sie uns bereits entdeckt
ein denkbares szenario wie ein us
forscherteam jetzt herausgefunden hat
die fachleute haben analysiert von
welchen nahegelegenen sternensystemen
neugierige bewohner in der lage wären
das leben auf der erde zu entdecken auf
vielen dieser sterne sind inzwischen
sogar radiosignale von uns eingetroffen
für wen im weiten kosmos sind wir also
die außerirdischen pixum sein feature
gibt es dreimal pro woche spannende
science videos abonniert den kanal und
aktiviert die glocke nur so verpasst ihr
nichts los geht's herzlich willkommen
und danke für den themenvorschlag von
jakob über unsere klicks um science and
future talibangruppe den link gibt es
dazu hier und da könnt ihr diskutieren
themen vorschlagen und bekommt die
videos früher und dann für kurze zeit
ganz ohne werbung stephen hawking hatte
immer wieder gewarnt dass die menschheit
sich lieber still verhalten sollte denn
ansonsten könnten außerirdische wesen
auf uns aufmerksam werden und für uns
zur gefahr werden
doch das ist schon längst geschehen wie
jetzt eine aktuelle studie zeigt demnach
können irdische signale bereits jetzt
von zahlreichen stellen im umkreis von
300 lichtjahre wahrgenommen werden
außerirdische zivilisation die über
ähnliche technologien wie wir verfügen
könnten demnach also schon längst über
uns bescheid wissen wie sind die us
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
bei ihrer analyse vorgegangen und was
bedeuten diese erkenntnisse für unsere
suche nach außerirdischem leben alle
spannenden antworten auf diese fragen
gibt es in diesem video
die us astrophysikerin lisa kaltenegger
hat schon seit jahren vor allem die
sogenannten exoplaneten im visier
gemeint sind damit planeten die um einen
anderen stern als unsere sonne kreisen
doch die suche nach ihnen ist nicht
einfach denn sie strahlen nur wenig
licht ab erst in den 90er jahren war es
überhaupt das erste mal gelungen exo
planeten aufzuspüren
bei der suche nach außerirdischem leben
konzentrieren sich die meisten
forschungsteams auf die entdeckung so
genannter ehrt
ähnlichen exoplaneten sie kreisen in der
lebensfreundlichen also habitablen zone
ihres mutter gestürmt und oft handelt es
sich zudem um felsplaneten der größte
etappensieg der astronomie wäre
sicherlich ein planet der genauso groß
ist wie die erde und viel wasser besitzt
zudem müsste er nicht so weit und nicht
zu nah seinen heimatplaneten umkreisen
und so leben ermöglichen laut der us
weltraumagentur nasa sind es
mittlerweile insgesamt rund 4400 22
bestätigte exoplaneten und 7450 mögliche
kandidaten laut dem stand vom 30 06 2010
eine ganz schöne menge so scheint es auf
den ersten blick vor allem werden es
durch die intensive forschung in diesem
bereich täglich mehr benutzt wird vor
allem die sogenannten transitmethode
sobald sich ein exoplanet von uns aus
gesehen vor seinen stern schiebt
erreicht uns periodisch etwas weniger
licht wodurch fachleute auf seine
existenz schließen können mehr als 3000
der rund 4400 bislang bestätigten
exoplaneten konnten durch diese
sogenannten transitmethode dingfest
gemacht werden manchmal werden
exoplaneten aber auch aufgrund der
sogenannten radialgeschwindigkeit
aufgespürt wenn der stern also ein
begleiter hat schwankt der
radialgeschwindigkeit der grund die
bewegung um den gemeinsamen schwerpunkt
und auch das können astronomie teams
wiederum durch licht verschiebungen
feststellen 20 prozent konnten so
gefunden werden direkt beobachtet werden
konnten sogar bislang auch einige
exoplaneten aber das nur in sehr
seltenen fällen trotz der intensiven
forschung in diesem bereich sind sich
fachleute einig dass es mit sehr hoher
wahrscheinlichkeit weitere unzählige
welten gibt von denen wir bislang nicht
einmal die leiseste ahnung haben allein
in unserer galaxie gibt es 200
milliarden sterne und wenn wir davon
ausgehen dass meistens planeten um sie
kreisen
das sind das auch hunderte milliarden
planeten forschende aus der astrophysik
suchen also akribisch nach den
exoplaneten in der sogenannten
habitablen also lebensfreundlichen zone
denn hier könnte aller voraussicht nach
leben theoretisch existieren dazu die
astrophysikerin lisa kaltenegger
es ist möglich dass ist im universum
um von lebensfreundlichen planeten
wimmelt wir wissen aber nicht ob leben
immer entsteht wenn es die möglichkeit
dazu gibt laut der us wissenschaftlerin
sind also vor allem die folgenden
exoplaneten besonders spannend bei
unserer suche nach leben im kosmos sind
planeten die von uns aus gesehen
regelmäßig vor ihren sternen vorüber
ziehen derzeit unsere besten kandidaten
diese chance nutzten die fachleute die
sich vor allem für die atmosphäre dieser
bislang rund 3400 aufgespürten planeten
interessieren
eine spannende frage dabei sind hier
gase wie methan oder sauerstoff zu
finden denn nachweis dieser gase könnte
nämlich darauf hinweisen dass ich dort
möglicherweise außerirdisches leben
gebildet hat durchaus vorstellbar ist es
auch dass die fachleute so eine
luftverschmutzung nachweisen können sie
durch eine technische zivilisation
verursacht wurde
in der fachsprache ist vom sogenannten
bio signaturen die rede
gesucht wird also nach speziellen
molekülen in der atmosphäre die eben nur
durch die existenz von lebewesen erklärt
werden können geologische prozesse wie
etwa vulkanausbrüche müssen dabei
ausgeschlossen werden hoffnung setzt die
fachwelt bei diesem unterfangen vor
allem auf neue teleskope die jetzt bald
an den start gehen beispielsweise das
james webb weltraumteleskop und hier auf
der erde das extremely large telescope
in chile vielversprechende exoplaneten
können damit gezielt auf bio signaturen
analysiert werden denn licht interagiert
mit materie kollidiert zum beispiel
sauerstoff atome miteinander blockieren
sie bestimmte teile des infraroten
spektrum so können die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
also zum beispiel schon mal herausfinden
ob überhaupt sauerstoff in der
atmosphäre vorhanden ist in ihrer
aktuellen studie hat lisa kaltenegger
vor allem eine frage inwieweit könnte
potenzielles leben auf anderen planeten
das leben auf der erde aufspüren für wen
also sind wir die aliens auf welchen
exoplaneten könnte also eine potenzielle
außerirdische zivilisation mit hilfe von
bio signaturen die existenz der
menschheit offenbaren dazu sagt sie aus
sicht eines exoplaneten wären wir
schließlich die aliens deshalb wollten
wir herausfinden wie viele sterne diesen
platz in der ersten reihe beim blick auf
unser sonne
system einnehmen dass wir von
außerirdischen auf einem exoplaneten
aufgespürt werden gar nicht so
unwahrscheinlich auch das könnte
gelingen wenn aus deren sicht die erde
vor der sonne vorbei zieht auch der hohe
sauerstoffgehalt der erdatmosphäre wäre
ein entscheidender hinweis für leben auf
der erde falls die potenzielle
außerirdische zivilisation auch
geeignete instrumente hätte könnten sie
zudem auch substanzen wie flo
kohlenwasserstoffe aufspüren
diese entstehen nicht durch natürliche
biologische vorgänge und wären somit
starke hinweise auf die existenz einer
technischen zivilisation auf der erde
das forschungsteam nahm für diese
analyse an dass solche potenziellen
außerirdischen zivilisationen dieselbe
oder ähnliche technologien zu hilfe
nehmen könnten die auch uns in den
kommenden jahren wie etwa mit dem james
webb weltraumteleskop zur verfügung
stehen zudem nahmen die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
aus den usa an
dass die erde auf ihrer bahn vor unserer
sonne vorbei zieht natürlich so gesehen
aus der perspektive der außerirdischen
zivilisationen in der fachsprache der
sogenannte air transat für die analyse
nutzte das forschungsteam die daten des
katalogs der europäischen
weltraumorganisation die gaia raum
sondern misst seit sieben jahren seit
2014 die position und bewegung von mehr
als einer milliarden sterne der
milchstraße diese sind ausführlich im
katalog beschrieben daraus
identifizierten sie insgesamt 2034
sternesystem im umkreis von 326 jahren
die einen eher dran sind jederzeit
zwischen 5000 jahren vor rund 5000
jahren in der zukunft beobachten könnten
das forschungsteam hat also dem zeitraum
von vor 5000 jahren den beginn der
ersten hoch zivilisation auf der erde
und bis 5000 jahre in die zukunft
analysiert das ergebnis ist wirklich
überraschend denn es handelt sich um
eine wirklich hohe zahl insgesamt sind
es rund 2000 sternensysteme in unserer
kosmischen nachbarschaft die in diesem
zeitraum ganz oder kurzfristig das
vorbeiziehen der erde von der sonne
beobachten können mit dabei unter
anderem der rote zwar groß 128 nur elf
lichtjahre von uns entfernt seine
bewohner wenn es sie denn gibt hätten
den er transit bereits vor 900 jahren
sehen
freien blick bekommt auch bald der stern
trapp ist eins der rund 40 lichtjahre
von uns entfernt ist zusammen mit seinen
sieben exoplaneten wird er in 1642
jahren in der transitzone eintreten und
diesen losen platz dann knapp 2400 jahre
lang beibehalten
75 sterne und ihre planeten haben sogar
schon die signale der tv- und
radiosendungen erreicht die auf der erde
vor rund 100 jahren gestartet wurden 29
möglicherweise sogar bewohnbare planeten
sind demnach sogar so gut platziert dass
sie die erde beobachten und belauschen
können und so sogar auf eine gewisse
intelligenz der menschheit schließen
könnten
und davon werden es immer mehr denn die
radiostrahlung breitet sich immer weiter
im all aus die grosse frage bleibt
natürlich was eine potenzielle
außerirdische zivilisation mit unseren
signalen anfängt suchen sie
möglicherweise aufgrund dessen den
kontakt mit uns dazu schreibt das
forschungsteam
es wird viel darüber diskutiert ob wir
aktiv signale aussenden oder lieber
unsere anwesenheit verbergen sollen
doch für solche überlegungen ist es
jetzt bereits zu spät denn unsere
atmosphäre hat sich bereits durch unsere
existenz verändert und außerirdisches
leben könnte bereits seit einer
milliarde jahren darüber bescheid wissen
dass es leben auf der erde gibt auch
dass sich mittlerweile eine technische
zivilisation entwickelt hat wird ihn
wenn es sie denn gibt sicherlich nicht
entgangen sein und vielleicht erforschen
sie uns ja bereits offiziell
es könnte außerirdisches leben geben usa
kann es nicht erklären anklicken
anschauen und abonnieren
das geht ganz einfach einfach auf den
abo button unter jedem video klicken das
ist kostenlos und macht schlau bis dann
bleibt dran